Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number
and that number is 2192. David P,
here's a caller who is understandably confused
about the great replacement theory stuff espoused
by the Buffalo shooter. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: Hey, David. That shooter in Buffalo
cited great replacement theory. That makes no
sense to me because it's not like. Black people in
this country, for the most part, are immigrants.
True. But. If their ancestors were forcefully
immigrate, immigrated over here, you could
say. But I just don't see the logic how
he would use that as an
excuse to kill that particular
demographic.
Speaker 1: I don't either.
Speaker 3: Do they actually believe
that? Black people are being.
Sent in here by Democrats or something.
Speaker 1: So here's what you have to
understand. It's it's a great point, which
is great replacement theory is focused
on forcing demographic changes upon the United
States through immigration. But for the most part,
the people that are coming to the United
States legally and illegally are not black
people as traditionally defined. So why would
you go and shoot black people if you're angry
about great replacement theory? All you have
to understand is this for a lot of these folks,
there's white people and then there's everybody
else. So it doesn't matter that great replacement
is more about the immigration of what we might
call brown, Latino, Hispanic people. And the
shooter went and targeted black people. It's just
it's all nonwhite people. Now, there sometimes an
exception. There's something called the ideal
immigrant story about Asian folks. So sometimes
these same people who are angry about black brown
people coming to the United States in order to
try to justify themselves not actually
being racist xenophobes, they'll go,
we're fine with people coming from. And they'll
usually list Asian countries. They'll say, like
South Korea and stuff like that. This is this is
called the model minority or the ideal minority.
It's another trope that's often part of this. So
but generally speaking, there if it's not white
people, that's their concern. And so that's
the connection between great replacement and
black folks, even though it doesn't actually make
much sense since most black folks are indeed born
here in the United States. I'm trying to explain
something that doesn't make sense, so I hope I've
at least explained what they believe accurately.
We have a great bonus show for you today. We are
going to talk about a Dutch doctor that will keep
sending abortion pills to American women. We will
explain how North Korea went from zero COVID to
1.2 million cases in just 72 hours. And we will
talk about a Supreme Court decision that will make
Ted Cruz a half a million dollars richer. All of
those stories and more on today's bonus show. Sign
up at. Join Pacman dot com. If you're waiting for
our big Memorial Day membership discount, you can
get on our newsletter at David Pakman dot com. And
on Monday, Memorial Day, you'll get an email
telling you how to sign up at a massive defense.